you can ask chat GPT why did mom jeans
get rebooted in the last two years after
being out of style for 25 years is this
a 90s thing is it a friends has gotten
popular on Netflix talk it through what
comes out of that is insane so like for
me as a strategist which is really
ultimately what I am I'm using AI to be
my thinking partner to my Curiosities
why are more young men wearing nail
polish in this generation that we
haven't seen before I'll give you the
answer when Tick Tock started popping
e-boys were like popping and they were
doing it and then basketball players
started doing it there was enough
momentum of people that were cool all of
a sudden a little Huddy and Jordan
Clarkson both wearing nail polish makes
a dude be like I want you too because
those guys are cool here would be
literally a question to ask if we start
a business tomorrow like we got to start
a fashion brand is there a scenario
where top hats for men could come back
if so what was it the three times that
it's happened in the last 200 years that
made it happen enter this is AI because
that shit's not coming up with anything
if you put that into Google